[Musique]
d'après les renseignements de mahé
données vous pouvez donc supporter un
loyer de 2500 francs mensuels oui c'est
ça mais charges comprises
un jeu complet et le secteur
géographique 18e 19e 20e
j'ai un appartement dans le 20e
arrondissement
bien situé place des fêtes exactement et
c'est fait c'est 1 85 mètre carré il ya
une cave un parking tout compris dans
les 2100 francs et c'est au 15e étage où
la lassitude ils devraient tous ah oui
c'est une c'est déjà un immeuble
imposant
c'est vraiment charmant ce soir
martin ne voulut pas visiter
l'appartement sans le secours de son ami
l'architecte
ce dernier savait d'expérience qui
serait de peu d'utilité rien étant moins
rationnels que ces choix là mais il va
décider à l'idée de sa présence sinon de
ses conseils oui quand l'appartement
on écoute ça peut-être dans une de ces
tours
il va falloir prouver le gardien way
plutôt 15e l'appartement en question
était à deux pas mais trouver la bonne
adresse dans la place des fêtes
bouleversé relevait du tour de force
il cherchait en vain dans leur mémoire
des points de repères mais rien ne
subsiste et de leurs souvenirs
dix mois les tours là ça vous écrase
complètement à sa elles sont présentes
ils ont tout de même garder les arbres
c'est ce qui reste de la place des fêtes
la petite maison tous les imams à quel
besoin derrière la grue maison d'éclat
thouars ou bien au 15e étage
et puis tout d'un coup tu découvres une
petite maison c'est là que tu aimes
réhabiliter pas forcément en france
avait son charme
j'ai rien contre la nostalgie mois
question en france jusque appartement
mais tu sais il ya toujours ce fameux
rapport qualité prix on n'a pas fini
d'entendre parler de moi c'est la forme
de ce parti ou de ce forum en parle de
forums et on se retrouve toujours
absolument toujours sur un parking avec
la place des fêtes avec elle
c'est incroyable c'est pouvoir qu'est ce
que c'est tu verras puisqu'on dit
nostalgique a plutôt montré des vrais
mon avis
et alors que c'est beau
vraiment très très bon
c'était des petites maisons ouvrières
junte et construite avec le matériau de
l'exposition de 19 cents
fantastique c'est chacun c'était des
constructions très très bon marché à
l'époque
aujourd'hui ça serait presque du luxe
fantastique
c'est vraiment très très beau parce que
c'est la première tour côté physique
oui mais c'est pas le premier à part 3
[Musique]
vraiment de sens
j'ai bien réfléchi à ce que tu cherches
oui
non
je crois question pertinente et qui
prouvait une certaine habitude refuser
les définitions est une bonne manière de
cultiver le hasard et martin ne
manquaient pas à la règle si bien
qu'après avoir sillonné le 19e le 20e
arrondissement
ils se retrouvèrent dans le xviie qui
est encore un vrai quartier disait-il
à défaut de trouver l'appartement idéal
martin prenait quelques cours
d'architecturé regarde ce carrefour
c'est typique de l'époque hausse manière
il ya un an seulement la ligne dans des
rues
mais aussi l'alignement des toits
tu vois ça fait
histoire même site même si sa vie même
si c'est un appartement ne donne pas
dessus ce sont des choses qui comptent
et qui ont compté sur nous
même si c'est pas de la bande à fifi
ça s'est fait petit à petit
et ça se sent
aujourd'hui c'est le problème que
l'homme
on a cru que les grands grand complexe
moderne allait fonctionner et puis non
[Musique]
refaire des petites places comme ça
ailleurs n'est pas non plus de solutions
devant
on a cru que le temps des expériences
était passé qu'on avait trouvé et puis
il faut continuer il faut chercher
encore et continuent les expériences
[Musique]
mais
roux
m
[Musique]
mais
là c'est plus le 20e ça se fait beaucoup
plus prestigieux mais c'est plus cher
aussi
curieux cette personne ce n'est pas une
place et la rue robert defer dirais
plutôt un décor de tertre n'est pas
gentil pour le théâtre
c'est plus soignée que dans le 20e
mais j'ai tout de même cette sensation
d'écrasement une mais ici ensemble plus
la pensée que derrière quel point c'est
l'idée de supprimer la circulation les
voitures la rue et c'est quand même pas
new york
quelle différence avec new york new york
est une ville
ici ce n'est qu'un îlot greffer dans la
ville
oui mais est-ce que tu habites ray ça a
un côté hlm prolonger celle m 10 mille
francs le mètre carré
tu vois tu as tous les éléments d'une
rue les boutiques les réverbères le
téléphone oui mais c'est désert
ah oui on n'a pas envie d'y flâner
je
qu'est ce que c'est que cette passerelle
c'est une passerelle provisoire
ça fait partie de la conception on est
toujours 10 mètres au dessus de la ville
c'est tout de même quelque chose de
fascinant c'est tout ce que je ne sais
pas si on vivrait longtemps dans une
sculpture
tu vois c'est complètement coupés de la
ville
[Musique]
on le croirait pas la rue du théâtre est
à deux pas passe même tout la donne
elle est annulée en tant que rue devient
un passage pour votre dur
c'est vrai
on oublie qu'on ait vingt quatre
c'est pourtant un vrai car nous gagnons
marque ça l'est encore
mais
certains endroits
[Musique]
après le choc des fonds de scène un
retour en arrière s'impose est un retour
en arrière dans le paris insolite
quel plaisir d'abandonner les visites
d'appartements et de se laisser glisser
comme un simple touriste
au fil du canal saint martin
[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]
et
e
oh
[Musique]
tiens là tout un échantillonnage de
construction modèle tu ne veux pas qu'on
essaye de voir ici
je crois que j'ai compris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est toutes les puces c'est vraiment
extraordinaire parce que ça traverse le
quartier
j'ai des petits ponts pour les piétons
des ponts qui remue c'est une machinerie
fascinant
[Musique]
c'est ce cas là on a failli en faire un
boulevard à nabeul
ah oui mais pas assez grosse machinerie
quand on perd on a tendance à les
supprimer pouvons faire des voiries
exemple circulation
voit ses espoirs alors voilà le meilleur
du square du canal mais on commence
maintenant pour percer là que c'est des
choses
[Musique]
c'est quoi ta wii s'est pas vu ma part
mais dans la partie qui est derrière la
butte je crois
parce que j'aime ces escaliers
quand tu vois c'est justement ce genre
de petites solutions là explique on a
plus aujourd'hui c'était ces
raccordements de bruit avec un escalier
ses trottoirs sceptiques remplacer même
courant c'est parti d'un fonds de savoir
qui on n'a pas trouvé l'équivalent
aujourd'hui tu vois la mythique
c'était tout bêta de petites solutions
qui était vraiment ce qui marche et
fonctionner
ce qui m'ennuie c'est côté touristique
avec le cas c'est pas sûr
aie aie je crois qu'en s'est encore
trompée il faut tourner au fond à droite
là bas y prendre goût à la musique de
fascinant
[Musique]
martin n'avait toujours pas
d'appartement mais elle savait
maintenant faire la différence entre une
façade 1930 et ne fasse à 10 900 bientôt
elle connaîtra les subtilités et
distinguerait le 1925 de 1930
[Musique]
en tout cas elle ne marchait plus que la
tête en l'air et apprenaient à regarder
paris
e
[Musique]
a envahi par le tourisme on s'y attend
le pactole
à côté village où finalement les
touristes sur un circuit et je ne se
sentent pas
l'udc l'a pas fait parce que je veux
je ne sais pas si leur leader du mais en
tout cas tu seras sur la butte
m
[Musique]
une charge avant
bah oui c'est un classique dans les
vieux quartiers
évidemment la maison et le petit jardin
je te préviens ça va être très dur à
trouver bien va soyons raisonnables
allons voir l'appartement moderne
alors je décide
je ne sais pas
je le trouve ça cher et puis je n'aime
pas les proportions de classe pourtant
la distribution est bonne tu es sûr que
tu aimes et moderne
je trouve qu'il manque de charme dommage
parce que j'aime bien ce quartier fille
la rue est belle les immeubles qui
présente bien
alors en craignent depuis une semaine
dans paris à la recherche d'un
appartement moderne et puis chaque fois
que tu rêves c'est devant une petite
foule faisant un petit jardin romantique
toujours que vous les insultez à gouffre
et du moderne qui fasse rêver pour mon
attitude sera peut-être différente
pourquoi ce que j'invite d'habiter du
moderne pour le côté pratique mais au
niveau du rêve d'enfin je me retourne
toujours dans l'ancien évidemment tu as
raison même si c'est tour ne sont pas
les plus beaux exemples de
l'architecturé moderne et même s'il
apporte le tas de résolve des tas de
solutions pratiques
ils ont détruit des très beaux quartiers
santé en chose et surtout pas le char et
même quand la ville est plus petit
c'est ça l'image entière qui était né
peut on pas d'accord j'attends du
moustique ou sli du risque d'attendre
longtemps
tout vaut mieux qu'on cherche le petit
jardin et le parti knk raison d'en
parler alors là attention doivent à
l'état de petites villes comme celle de
la presse des faits
regarde il y en a à gauche et puis plus
loin qui on aura aussi à droite
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
et voilà la petite maison cher au coeur
des français n'a pas fini de faire des
ravages
mais par pitié messieurs les architectes
et nous abandonnez pas au passé ici
délivrez nous du fonctionnel et inventé
nous des lieux qu'ils nous fassent rêver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autour
[Musique]
et
pour
mais
[Musique]
non
et